die hatte war schon im westen von
jerusalem
es ist ein mahnmal und ein museum
zugleich die erinnerung an die ermordung
der juden europas die shoah ist nicht
nur fest im bewusstsein der israelis
verankert sie ist teil der israelischen
staatsraison nie wieder etwas ms der ort
an dem der ganzen welt die bösartigkeit
aber auch die absurdität von
antisemitismus und rassismus
zweifelsfrei vor augen geführt wird
nicht nur in den augen von professor
daniel blattmann der seit jahrzehnten in
yad vashem forscht und arbeitet eine
einzigartige institution jad vaschem ist
ohne zweifel heute die führende
institution in der erinnerung an den
holocaust
aber genauso auch führend als ein
forschungsinstitut eine riesige
verantwortung für die person welche die
holocaust-gedenkstätte leiten soll
die ansprüche sind dementsprechend hoch
wir waschen kann nicht arbeiten ohne
konsens und verbundenheit mit der
gesamten welt der internationalen
akademischen aber auch nicht weniger mit
der jüdischen welt umso größer der
weltweiter aufschrei dass ein als ultra
nationalistische bekannter politiker
designiert wurde der mit grob
rassistischen ausfällen gegen
israelische araber und palästinenser von
sich reden machte so forderte der ex
general die arabischen bewohner aus
teilen des westjordanlandes zu
vertreiben
gegen die berufung von item gingen
zuletzt sogar holocaust-überlebende auf
die straße sie befürchten das ansehen
und der auftrag von yad vashem könnte
schaden nehmen
organisiert hat den protest der
88-jährige heimroth als kind in holland
entkam er nur knapp der deportation und
ermordung durch die nazis von der
familie getrennt überlebte er dank der
hilfe von freunden ständig auf der
flucht
die deutschen also ss und gestapo haben
mich buchstäblich anderthalb jahre
gehabt aber ich wurde an verschiedenen
orten versteckt
nach dem krieg kehrte ich zu meinen
eltern zurück die überlebt hatten
mein bruder überlebte nur meine beiden
schwestern und überlebten nicht
sie wurden in auschwitz ermordet gerade
wegen der erfahrungen seines lebens
müsse er gegen die berufung items
protestieren
es gibt einiges was er in der
vergangenheit gesagt hat das meiner
meinung nach und nach der viele andere
holocaust-überlebender rassistisch ist
und an der spitze eines
prestigeträchtigen instituts für jad
vaschem dass rassismus und
antisemitismus bekämpft sollte nicht so
ein mann stellt so einfach
nominiert wurde item von einem weg und
minister mit unterstützung von
ministerpräsident netanjahu wie es heißt
von der regierung auf anfrage aber kein
kommentar und auch ihm selbst ist zu
keinem interview bereit dass er die
israelisch arabischen abgeordneten in
der knesset als krebszellen und fünfte
kolonne bezeichnet hat ist für die nur
ein teil des problems opfer massiv ist
jude gehört aber selbst zur größtenteils
arabischen abgeordneten gruppe der joint
liszt als ort des interviews hat er das
denkmal für die jüdischen kämpfer gegen
die nationalsozialisten vorgeschlagen
es ist als ob in deutschland wir an
hecke vom rechten flügel der afd der
verantwortliche für das
holocaust-mahnmal in berlin werden würde
einsam ist rassist er unterstützt die
deportation von palästinensern aus ihrem
heimatland diesen mann für eine
institution jad vashem zu nominieren ist
das exakte gegenteil von dem ohr an die
opfer der nazi ständen würden
doch warum wird eine so umstrittene
persönlichkeit vietnam ausgerechnet für
den direktorenposten von jad vaschem
nominiert professor blattmann vermutet
politisch ideologische gründe etwa
schwimmen kombiniert beides die jüdische
erinnerung an den holocaust die
natürlich für das jüdische volk
einzigartig ist aber zur selben zeit
internationale werte eine botschaft an
die ganze welt dass dies eben nicht nur
eine jüdische erinnerung ist sondern ein
weltumspannendes anlegen
das mit internationalen wertmaßstäben
betrachtet werden sollte falls es die
absicht von netanjahu sein sollte jad
vaschem in eine kleine nationalistische
und chauvinistische einrichtung
umzuformen dann könnte er mit am erfolg
haben
[Musik]
entscheiden muss am ende das israelische
kabinett über die personalie noch ist
die zukunft von jad vaschem offen